Well,
hello, how are you? Sali Jaramillo greets you
with the briefing for today, Monday
, March 15. The state will open up to 50
percent capacity starting
today,
this includes restaurants and casinos, but it is
not only businesses that are already
allowed to expand.
groups of up to 250
people will also now be allowed on may first the
governor said there will be fewer
restrictions on expansion at
other government sites and
overall
as it will be a big transition day
for clark county school district staff
for the first time  in a year
several workers return to the
facilities this is part of the plan
to return to school for grades 6 9 and
12 next Monday under
hybrid learning the other grades are expected to
return until April 6 it is also
possible that all grades
return to class in
person 5 days a week after
spring break and
vice pre  sidenta- kamala harris will be
visiting las vegas' today accompanied by
her husband dobles and hold she will
attend several places including the
vaccination clinic located in la and an audi and
the culinary academy of las vegas
after her tour
xerez will head to the  angeles and now
we turn to the weather forecast
temperatures are expected in the 60s with a
chance of rain this afternoon
until tonight as well as very strong winds
good start to the week I am from
Jaramillo and this was your brief
informative in Spanish
[Music]